哈囉我是小燈雷
我的粉絲終於到達10萬等啦
我是在今年的25號發的
我決定做我主持後的第一天領寄
然後在8月20號內天我的粉絲突破了10萬大關
有非常感謝各位爸爸的支持
所以這期視頻是為了感謝你們
其實我在一個多月之前
我就已經發了50萬號了
但我們想到我9萬粉絲找到10萬粉絲找了那麼漫長
那我們來一起看一下我跟你們準備的什麼理物吧
這個是我最喜歡的現裝膠是躲煩的
我買了10份
用它現裝的感覺就是不是覺得幾正在現裝
而是在做一個親友面模的感覺
相為非常好文很療癒
而且裡面有很多的樣負成分
它的正確用法是先晚一圖
在手上然後在手心樓開之後
在按你按上面
人臉上的彩妝和現裝膠充分的容件之後
在入化用清水死掉
它的這個入化的速度非常快
一點都不用擔心因為入化服徹底
而導致長鬥鬥
幾晚之後面上一點融握感都沒有很清爽
洗得很乾淨
動它洗完之後完全不需要再二次清潔了
我皮膚明感的時候用它現裝也好無壓力
然後就是一個我很喜歡的面模
我也買了10份
它的使用感很好模
不就像活動一樣子在臉上冰冰原量的
舒緩和補水的效果都很好
而且它是膚料
所以我們做完一些光片的效果也可以扶它
我準備長10個一直支持我的粉絲把綁嫩
每人送一個卸妝膏和面模
歡迎你們來這條視頻上跟我留言喔
我之後會分享關於更多的店美的小明明
希望你們的皮膚都變得水平淋的
那我們下次見 掰掰